we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard
or they are hard it is 45 years since
man last walked on the moon and the
space race slowed to a crawl the Apollo
missions were described as the last
great optimistic act of the 20th century
and they were followed by an era of
public indifference but we stand at the
dawn of a new space area which is
defined more by commercial gain and
personal vanity space is no longer the
exclusive playground of nation-states
texts billionaires like Elon Musk and
Jeff Bezos have joined the game they
dream of space tourism and asteroid
mining and sending voyages to Mars these
are new acts of 21st century optimism
and a very different kind of space race
rapid and complete reusability is really
the key to opening up space if we can
reduce the cost of watched by a factor
of 10 and then by a factor of 100 you
will be living in a completely new world
[Music]
Space Exploration is madly expensive
because this never happens
escaping Earth's gravitational field
takes a huge amount of energy that
equation is never going to change but
there are other ways for cost to tumble
for a long time
reusable rockets were thought to be
impossible now the new launch providers
such as SpaceX have turned that view on
its head and change the economics of
spaceflight forever the cost of taking a
6-ton satellite into space is dropping
dramatically so nowadays several
operators are offering the potential to
recover the rocket some of these Rockets
are actually able to be landed on a
platform to save it and reuse it and
obviously if you can reuse a launch
rocket again and again and again it
dramatically reduces the cost of taking
your asset to space
Rupert Pierce is the chief executive of
Inmarsat at this point his satellite is
going to be the heaviest payload SpaceX
has ever launched we have teams of
people who've worked maybe four or five
years on that piece of ironmongery you
know it's a huge piece of their career
right there on the launch pad and they
know in the next 10 seconds it could
evaporate and be of just a very very
large firework quite a moment
I'm standing on satellite beach in
Florida among the surfers and the
Pelican just down the coast from Cape
Canaveral up there where SpaceX launches
its rocket so in mass that's I five
satellite is going to be launched off
into space tomorrow but if it was
sitting on this beach how big would it
be let's have a look it would measure
about 3.5 meters by 3.5 meters it also
stands 7 meters high about the height of
a double-decker bus and weighs just
under 6 tons but if the rocket goes off
without a hitch and the satellite
successfully deploys in space then the
solar panels will extend to a length of
about 33 meters when arthur c clarke
wrote about extraterrestrial relays
orbiting the earth the year was 1945 now
they are multi-billion dollar industries
we all watch rocket launches on TV and
think that space the real space money
comes from direct to home television and
GPS products and services so things that
affect our lives day to day things that
have global markets that's where you
make money in space
there are three main reasons for space
travel to understand earth to understand
the wider universe and soon maybe to
turn Homo sapiens into an interplanetary
species on the day of the launch as I
caused a glimpse of the rocket about to
leave Earth and deploy a satellite to
look back upon us I couldn't help
remembering the people who had been here
before
[Music]
in 1969 Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and
Michael Collins blasted off from this
historic launch pad at Cape Canaveral
and they went to the moon which you can
see just behind the rocket there next
year SpaceX which have built this rocket
are intending to take two very rich fee
paying astronauts to the other side of
the Moon and bring them safely back home
this place really is a portal between
two worlds the stakes are not as high
today as they were in 1969 but every
rocket launch generates both
exhilaration and anxiety 30 seconds
Falcon I did start up ten nine eight
seven six five four three
we have liftoff that is amazing the
light which is extraordinary and now you
can account for ring of nine it
but now he feel around shaking in the
noise
once it clears the launchpad the light
becomes that and looking the blinding
quite painful to look at it at that
point and the noise becomes absolutely
overwhelming this is max Q which is when
the rocket is under the maximum stress a
lot of the SpaceX guys say that it's a
real kind of visceral feeling to
experience a launch like this and I now
understand exactly what they're talking
about
it really does get you in the chest here
you see this thing going up at
unbelievable speed and within 30 minutes
it will be in outer space and it will be
deploying the satellite so that's the
first stage of separation now and you
can hear all the cheering in the
background we've been quite happy I've
always wanted to come and see a space
launch at Cape Canaveral breathtaking
government agencies like NASA and
Russia's Roskosmos used to be the only
way to explore space but SpaceX has
leased launch pad 39a from NASA for 20
years if the new space companies are in
the ascendant what does it mean for the
traditional space agencies is it only up
to them to study and understand the
wider universe my name is Charlie Bolden
and I am the 12th
NASA Administrator it's been 34 years in
the marine corps 14 in the middle of
that was spent in NASA's astronaut
office where I had the privilege of
flying for space shuttle missions
including two on the beautiful vehicle
behind us called discovery when we
deployed the Hubble Space Telescope that
has opened up the universe to us going
to space was science fiction when I grew
up in Columbia South Carolina a 17 year
old kid anywhere around the world today
has not taken a single breath when
people have not been living and working
on the International Space Station
[Music]
what is it about spaceflight that brings
people together one is the view of the
planet there are no borders there are no
boundaries I like to tell people we live
in one oh [ __ ] not multiple ocean and
their little bodies of land that stick
up and that is obvious I mean just
immediately it strikes you when you get
to space and you look back on our planet
I'm asked frequently what about
commercial companies I am in love with
them I was a healthy skeptic when I
became the NASA Administrator in 2009
and my skepticism was based on
commercial ideologues people who
believed then and some still believed
just get NASA out of the business
get government's out of the business
just give all the money to entrepreneurs
and alike and they'll do it all and I
just don't believe that I think there
are some things that one are too
expensive too risky for entrepreneurs
and commercial entities to do today
going out and blazing the trail to Mars
I think is the responsibility of
agencies like NASA Andres cosmos and
then bring commercial entities along as
we can not everyone believes in the hype
of the new space entrepreneurs Mariana
Matt ceccato is a leading economist who
contributed to a NASA study on the
economy of space I want to call them
entrepreneurs the word entrepreneur
means you know risk-taking and you know
forming new markets and actually I think
all the different actors in space
including NASA has an entrepreneurial
role and just labeling the companies as
entrepreneurs and then looking at NASA
as this sort of inertial dinosaur I
think it's part of the problem so for
example when we have space tourism why
is the entire price of that ticket for
the very rich of space tourists why does
it all go to companies like SpaceX and
not a penny to the public infrastructure
which has actually enabled that should
we should NASA get a payback should the
government get a payback from all these
things that you've made possible should
you know should entrepreneurial firms be
required to pay something to the
government my answer is no they pay tax
they create they generate revenue they
create a new end
three all of that results in funds to a
government the Goldman Sachs report on
spaces the next investment frontier
calculated that venture capital funds
had sunk more than thirteen billion
dollars into space projects so far this
century they believe that it could
become a multi trillion dollar market
within the next two decades so the
question of why are VCS investing in
space right now is a very interesting
one the VCS are not investing in space
because space is cool these seas are
investing in space because they see an
opportunity for ten times returns or 100
times returns in certain kinds of
ventures the adventures are typically
small satellite ventures in the hundreds
of millions of dollars not multiple
billions and hundreds of millions of
dollars as a total investment cost is
much more aligned with realistic VC
investments than multiple billions
that's just not the level of capital
that VCS typically are operating at but
if venture capital firms are transfixed
by the market for Cube sets the Silicon
Valley Giants have their eyes on a much
bigger prize at much longer
odds Mars we can bring life as we know
it and breathe life into Mars where it
doesn't exist today I think a future
where we are a specialization and out
there among the stars is infinitely more
exciting and inspiring than one where we
are not
SpaceX's stated goal is for humanity to
become an interplanetary species long
before Elon Musk began to plan for Mars
Kim Stanley Robinson had already been
there the visionary science fiction
author wrote the Mars trilogy imagining
how a hundred scientists would set up a
base on Mars when we met at the Royal
Greenwich Observatory in London I asked
him why Mars car such as well you can
see it with the naked eye that matters
the fascination comes from this
combination of real but empty what's
your best guess about when man will
reach Mars put it this way if their
human community decided it was a
priority then we could be on the planet
in about 10 to 15 years but it is it's
expensive and you can't make a profit
from it you simply can't
Mars is I get asked all the time is this
are you guys kidding and the answer is
no we're not kidding it's it's it's
within our grasp we're closer to sending
humans to Mars today than we've ever
been the business case for cargo was
easy humans is a little bit harder that
I am I am still not convinced that that
we have a business case for humans going
to Mars most people come up with the
same response we can't put a dollar
value on it however it's something that
we cannot not do president Donald Trump
also appears to see the value of
stepping onto another planet
tell me Mars what do you see a timing
for actually sending humans to Mars well
I think is your bill directed it'll be
approximately in the 2030s
unfortunately spaceflight takes a lot of
time and money so getting there will
require some international cooperation
what we want to try and do it during my
first term or at worst during my second
term so we'll have to speed that up a
little bit okay when President Trump was
talking to the astronauts on ISS the
other day he seemed to indicate that it
could be done within within his time
frame I disagree with the president I
you know you can do anything but there's
a saying in aviation that that a vision
without finance is a hallucination the
2030s are about that's about as early as
we
can do it you're from the financial
times so you understand that about you
you can talk big talk all you want but
if you're not putting money toward it it
ain't going to happen
we can learn a lot from earlier eras of
exploration to understand how things may
play out in space in future in the 19th
century everybody was focused on
communes get to the North Pole and then
when that happened communes get to the
South Pole then it was Mount Everest and
in 1953 we got to the top of Mount
Everest then it was the moon and in 1969
we got to the moon it has to be pointed
out that in each of these cases once we
got their interest in that place per se
fell off drastically people claim a huge
interest in Mars in fact it's dead Rock
and poisonous you can't go outdoors
you'd have to live underground so the
moment we land on Mars people who say I
wonder if we can get to the moons of
Jupiter I wonder if we can get to the
moons of Saturn and so on when you talk
about it as maybe a tourist destination
the trivializing of space is just almost
absurd and it becomes like the
equivalent of bungee jumping you know
bungee jumping you jump up a bridge you
stretch you go down you come back up oh
how wonderful bungee jumping upwards is
going up into space you spend a half a
million dollars to do it and then you
come back down is that really all space
was for rich persons bungee jumping I
don't think so and nobody thinks so in
2006 Anousheh Ansari became the first
woman to travel into space as a paying
astronaut she paid 20 million dollars
for the trip sitting on top of the
rocket you know you would think that it
will be a very powerful and jarring
experience and it is a powerful
experience but you don't feel it as much
when you're you see Earth from space
the feeling you get the that image stays
with you for the rest of your life
it's very difficult to put it towards
but the the first feeling that I got is
that my god this is a planet that's
alive you almost feel a life force and
energy heat coming from it so beautiful
and you look around and there's nothing
else like it space exploration has
always ocellated between the outlandish
and inspirational the new billionaires
are now rekindling the optimism of the
early space era and daring to extend the
frontiers of humanity you can't even
tell where one country start and the
other one stop all those things that
creates conflict just melts away and
then you can see our planet as one home
for all of us
and that's an image that I hope you know
world leaders could be because the
policy they would come up with would be
very different
so you would like to spend President
Trump into space I would like to send
all world leaders including President
Trump Rafi
[Music]
you